the Joe Rogan experience yeah well the
whole environment in Australia is so
strange and now because of the wildfires
you know there's a lot of species like
that was we were just talking the other
day about the koala bears yeah that the
koala bears a lot of their habitat got
burnt you know a lot of these fires
really sad he's really said there's on
fire and it's awful there's such a
little cute little animal they are but
and I don't have a lot of first-hand
experience with them my understanding is
they're actual jerks like they're really
cute and cuddly looking but their
behavior is pretty aggressive and
jerkish and I don't know enough about
them to really comment on it but my
understanding is it's kind of like sea
otters right do you know about this
thing with sea otters what about them so
like everybody loves sea otters are so
cute they're so cuddly sea otters are
super destructive they rape each other
like they're they're like gnarly animal
they're like not that sweet at all isn't
that everything with pandas too like
pandas are ruthless yeah totally
yeah but you look at them and you're
like oh yeah miss sweetiepie
my youngest daughter is really into
polar bears oh yeah polar bears are
adorable and she wanted to get like a
stuffed polar bear and I find it so
fascinating that that animal which is
the most ruthless of all bears for sure
we associate with Klondike bars and
coca-cola everybody's buddy and they're
sliding around the snow and I almost
want to like show her like this is what
they do to seals right go out go out
there and just show a video I want to
show her I know she's not looking it
yeah yeah like that picture there's this
image of this seal and they they all
have red faces from blood what did they
ever do they ever figure out that one
polar bear that was in Russia that had
been sprayed it said like t-34 on it you
see it in that image right there that
one Jamie I don't know about that right
there
someone had spray-painted T and the
number 34 on the side of a bear's body
and they don't know what happened that's
extremely ballsy it's a spray paint a
polar bear how do they do it
and then the real concern is that this
bear is going to have a real hard time
hunting
because they're gonna be able to see it
much better because of the fact that it
has the spray paint on the side of it
huh I've never I've never seen this
story before it's really yeah they don't
know they have no idea what happened
here it is Russian scientists search for
polar bear with black t-34 spray
painting on its side
cruel joke can turn deadly for a
predator now too visible for both prey
and poachers right yeah do they have a
hard time with protein they have a real
issue with certain towns in Siberia that
elect on the outskirts where polar bears
are invading and they have like dozens
of polar bears entering their towns they
they they've even evacuated towns
because of so many polar bears being
there from what I've heard would you
imagine just having an army of polar
bears roll into town you know you have a
town of like 150 people and in come
eight polar bears one day it's like what
what can you do it's nothing you get out
you're gonna kill them you gonna shoot
them with rifles are you gonna get out
right you probably should just get out
yeah you should get out yeah I mean it's
the polar bears a strange like bears in
general or strange animal because people
love them because we grew up with teddy
bears right and we see Yogi and there's
like they're so lovable yeah on
television and the movies yeah and so
people have this idea of them like they
want to take bear selfies like hey take
a beer selfie like how many people get
Jack taking bear selfies yeah no that's
a real thing I I have been contacted by
people being like hey why don't you like
not pose with wildlife because it's
influencing other people to do that I'm
like I'm a biologist he's my job I don't
have another option here like I have to
pose with wildlife like I'm working with
it like supposed to you are the guy the
guy like maybe instead don't do what I
do you know don't just jump out and try
get a selfie with Sally that's gonna
kill you I think it's common sense
[Applause]